good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight a little over 15 months
ago a group of chinese scientists
working
on the ground at the scene of the
outbreak of a brand new virus
came to the conclusion that the novel
coronavirus probably escaped from a
government lab in wuhan
these chinese scientists said that in
the clearest possible terms and then
posted on the internet
from our perspective this struck us as
an amazing and important story and also
by the way plausible
we expected a flurry of media interest
in it where did this virus come from
that seemed worth knowing as people were
dying of it but no one asked the
question
instead there was silence punctuated
only by occasional smirking about
anti-asian racism and conspiracy
theories
and that's where it stood for more than
a year until just a few weeks ago
then suddenly for reasons we still don't
really understand
all the smirking morons in the american
news media changed their view completely
overnight of course corona escaped from
a chinese virology
lab duh what do you think it came from a
wet market come on
that was the new consensus an avalanche
of evidence followed the wall street
journal confirmed
that the first corona victim seemed to
have been researchers working with bat
viruses at the wuhan institute of
virology buzzfeed then obtained
thousands of emails showing that tony
fauci
knew from the beginning that kovit may
have been manufactured in china
in dangerous experiments he helped pay
for
the lab league theory it turns out was
never crazy
it was always likely true
so why did they lie to us about it for
so long
a shocking new piece in of all places
the celebrity suckup magazine
vanity fair answers that question in
great detail
you should read it in short many
research scientists are addicted to
american tax dollars
if the american public understood just
how recklessly they have behaved
endangering the entire world with their
weird little experiments in poorly
regulated labs in
china that money might dry up
as a former nsc official called jamie
metzel put it succinctly quote
if the pandemic started as part of a lab
leak it had the potential to due to
virology what three mile island and
chernobyl did to nuclear science
can't have that got to keep the money
flowing so they lied about it
and then they intimidated anyone who
tried to tell the truth
that would include the director of the
cdc robert redfield redfield receives
death threats from scientists after he
suggested the virus may have come from a
lab
i am of the point of view that i still
think the most likely
etiology of this pathogen and wuhan was
a from a laboratory
you know escaped other people don't
believe that that's fine science will
eventually figure it out it's not
unusual for respiratory pathogens
that are being worked on in a laboratory
to infect the laboratory worker
it's not some guy in twitter that's the
former director of the cdc so you think
the world would
stop and ask follow-up questions such as
why do you think that where's the
evidence
but that's not what happened quote i was
threatened and ostracized because i
proposed another hypothesis
redfield told vanity fair i expected it
from politicians
i didn't expect it from science but
maybe he should have
redfield had dared to buck the orthodoxy
that had been imposed by the global
scientific establishment
it began on february 19 2020
just as the virus was getting to this
country and scaring the hell out of all
of us
at that moment one of the leading
science journals in the world the lancet
published a letter that was signed by 27
scientists
that letter declared flatly and for all
time that the chronovirus did not
originate in a lab in wuhan
and you'd have to be a bigot to believe
otherwise
now that letter we now know was
organized by peter dazyk
desicc is a man with everything to gain
by pretending that kovid came from a wet
market
desert was involved in gain of function
research at the wuhun institute of
virology
emails show that peter dezek carefully
selected other signatories to the lancet
letter
so that this obviously disqualifying
conflict of interest
would remain secret at one point dasic
wrote to another scientist called ralph
barrick who was also working on gain of
function research in china
telling him not to sign the letter
here's why quote
we'll put it out in a way that doesn't
link it back to our collaboration
so we maximize an independent voice end
quote
so the whole thing was a fraud and yet
it worked it was in the lancet everyone
trusts the lancet
in fact tony fauci himself cited dasig's
letter as proof that the virus was not
caused by research he was funding
if you look at the evolution of the
virus in bats
and what's out there now it is
very very strongly leaning towards this
could not have been
artificially or deliberately manipulated
the way the mutations have naturally
evolved
a number of very qualified evolutionary
biologists
have said that everything about the
stepwise evolution over time
strongly indicates that it evolved in
nature and then jumped species
of course it couldn't have been us so
really this is a story about the
self-licking ice cream cone that is the
federal bureaucracy
no matter how badly they screw up it's
never their fault
oh we didn't imagine wmd in iraq etc
pick your screw up it's your fault
racist
but it wasn't just tony fauci and the
federal bureaucrats who cited that
letter
self-described fact checkers the one who
control the flow of information in our
country now
used the lancet letter to censor anyone
on social media
who mentioned the possibility of a lab
leak it can't be true the lancet says
it's not true
27 eminent scientists say it's not true
only a few scientists in the face of all
of this dared to speak up
one of them was called jill dumanis he
formed a group of researchers called
drastic that's an acronym for
decentralized radical autonomous search
team something that all scientists
should be
jamie metzel the former nsc official
soon joined the group
almost immediately as early as april of
last year it was becoming clear to
metzel
that the lab league theory was not a
conspiracy theory in fact it was
plausible
i think that if i had to just bet based
on what i've read
and logic i would bet it's most likely
this was an accidental
leak from a lab
it turns out that metzel wasn't exactly
speculating on that
unlike the scientific establishment he
and drastic had
evidence that they had bothered to
gather they found that the official
scientific consensus had in fact been
doctored at the source in one instance
they discovered that xi jing li the bat
lady in wuhan
had collected samples of a bat corona
virus that were virtually identical to
covet 19.
where did she get these samples well she
found them in
a cave in the yunnan province in china
several miners had been killed there
after inhaling the
bat guano left by these bats she
recognized this virus was significant
because it had moved directly to humans
without going through an intermediate
animal host first the chinese seem to be
looking for the most
dangerous virus they could find and in
that cave they found it
after the chronovirus pandemic began xi
jing li tried to hide that kovid 19
was virtually identical to this virus
that she had collected in the mine
in her records she renamed the virus to
hide its source
peter dazyk then published a paper with
xi jinglee categorizing
all the various chronovirus strains they
had encountered in recent years
the paper listed hundreds of them and
yet somehow and you'll be surprised by
this
they omitted the deadly viruses found in
the yunnan mine
funny were those viruses significant
well the government of china appears to
think they are late last year
journalists with the bbc
tried to visit that mind to get some
answers and when they got there they
were followed by plainclothes police
officers
they found the road to the mine had been
blocked by a broken down truck
so the chinese government covered this
up but here's the worst part and the
most shocking part if you're an american
some within the u.s government helped
them cover it up they knew all
along this was going on but they buried
the truth too
because their interests were aligned
with the interests of the chinese
government
christopher park a director in the state
department's non-proliferation bureau
told the agency's investigators quote
not to say anything that would point to
the u.s government's own role in gain of
function
research now why would he say that
it turns out that christopher park was
involved in the 2017 decision
a world-changing decision it turned out
to lift the federal moratorium
on funding gain of function research
vanity fair obtained a memo from thomas
diana
who was then the acting assistant
secretary of the state department's arms
control bureau
in that memo he wrote that staff from
two state department bureaus had warned
leaders within his
office quote not to pursue an
investigation
into the origin of covet 19 because it
would quote
open a can of worms these are americans
working to hide the truth of the origin
of covet 19
from a country that's been destroyed by
covet 19.
you can't prevent outbreaks unless you
know where they came from and yet
federal bureaucrats prevented us from
learning where this one came from
one of the officials who wanted to shut
down the probe was chris ford
acting under secretary for arms control
and international security
a former administration official with
direct knowledge of the probe direct
knowledge
tells this show that chris ford was
briefed about the lab leak investigation
earlier than december 2020 when ford
claims he first heard about it we are
told that ford wanted it shut down
he was overruled by the secretary of
state at the time mike pompeo
ford by the way was not a permanent
bureaucrat he was a political appointee
but he spoke for many in the career
bureaucracy many of whom we are told
wanted to bury the probe out of
political animus they didn't like the
administration they served
and they didn't want to give it points
they accused anyone who asked
questions about where the virus came
from of being a conspiracy theorist
and in our conformist culture that's
enough to shut people up
in other words they acted just like the
people you see on tv just like msnbc
anchors
they did not act like federal officials
who have been sworn to protect american
lives
they weren't protecting american lives
they're protecting the consensus
and that endangered american lives as
for actual msnbc anchors
well they have regressed to a childlike
state of incoherence
watch this dopey little fan girl swoon
over tony fauci like he's the bassist in
a boy band
as you learn more and more you've got to
continue to evolve
with the data and that's what i was
trying to do is to always tell the truth
on the basis of what the data is and it
was never deliberately
something against the president in fact
you spoke about my emails
you look at my emails i never in the
email said anything derogatory
about president trump
well the true mark of someone is if they
look good even when their personal
emails come out so you pass the test
that very few of us
would pass i love you tony fauci
still talking about trump that's where
some of them still are
but there are still adults in this
country hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else